I didn't plan this but I feel like we're
very I know we are very February I love
it very February it is lovely to meet
you we have been in an elevator once um
yes we both this is a real story a true
story
we and first of all I'm so sorry if you
met Peter yet we have it but now we have
okay now you're besties that's right
yeah anyway so we this is a real story
we were on an elevator when tweets to
live in the same condo I'd heard that
she's also if you don't know this she's
also married to Caleb from Kings of Leon
and and I had heard that y'all lived in
the building and I had never seen him
and so we're all the cinnamon in the
elevator and you're like with a stroller
and you know you can't I couldn't see it
cuz we all were kind of looking down but
I was like you can feel the vibe of rock
and roll like like you enter a place and
you're like I don't belong like it's
like they were so cool and I was
literally like should I say anything no
and I don't look like me like I had no
makeup on my weave was gone no lashes
like it's like I did not look like me
and I was a game also you were thinking
the same way we literally cuz Kelly had
just covered my husband song used
somebody and we just watched it them
that morning and she is standing in
front of us and Caleb is so shy and I'm
like we were all like - who's gonna say
hi first and then Kelly walks off and
I'm like Caleb why didn't you say
anything
oh and I did it because I'm not gonna go
to the rock and roller and be like
accepted like I'm not gonna never go
like blown away by we both are so blown
away that he loved that I'm blown away
by him I've seen them actually a few
times in Nashville and you live in my
favorite - so wait you're okay you're
first this is crazy
your first Sports Illustrated swimsuit
cover was with Chrissy Teigen Chrissy
it's hilarious and Nina is so sweet and
we had so much fun on that shoot I mean
we were just like giggling the whole
time and there's also the it was covered
with sea cucumber sundress so it's like
we look all safe we were like trying not
to step on sea cucumbers it was like
riddled which is a fact about this shoe
not sexy at all
oh my god I love how glorious it looks
and you don't know the backstory you had
there was enough no glamour behind the
hot that would have been a fun shoot
though she's hilarious
she is yes but why did you create a
fragrance um you know I just love beauty
I love fashion and beauty and all that
fun stuff and I was just lucky enough to
get to create this beautiful fragrance
yeah
no wood glued it down down you cannot
touch your precious gonna like so what
so there's two right yes so I created
this fragrance and Haven is the first
one she's based on Nashville
my love of Nashville and it's very
floral and feminine and this one summit
is leather and tobacco and really just
yummy and intoxicating it was very
different is that supposed to be the
more like the mailing because that's
kind of more my love that meet you it's
like a gender gender neutral gender news
you sent my husband loves that one and
you know they're just fun and it's fun
to create probably of colognes and
perfumes I love it because you can
literally feel like total crap and you
spray it and you're like I was to go
home smelling like that
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this